hi and welcome to this
first of a set of webinars on practical
applications of machine learning to
behavioral science
and applied organometrics more broadly
joined with ideas 42
i am jan spiess i am an assistant
professor of operations
information and technology at the
graduate school of business of stanford
university
and also an affiliate of the capital
social impact lab
in this first chapter of our webinar i
will give an introduction
to machine learning from an applied
perspective
specifically i will target researchers
and practitioners of applied
econometrics
who think about how to add machine
learning to the econometric
toolbox and are interested in learning
how novel tools based on machine
learning can improve
practical empirical analysis
when we think of machine intelligence we
may think of
futuristic scenes like this one from ex
machina where a machine takes on human
form and can communicate to us
as if it was a human so this may be kind
of futuristic machine intelligence and
not what we have right now however
there is a lot of machine intelligence
that is already available to us and that
we have in our pockets
every day so just to give you one
example uh facebook for example
recognizing not just where in a picture
is a face but also which of your friends
is in that picture
is an amazing feat of machine
intelligence that is already available
to all of us another example would be
google translate
so google translate is not only able
to take a picture of some written text
convert this picture into something a
computer can understand
but also then to take that text and
translate it into a different language
and then further superimpose that
new translated sentence over the
original one
so all this is available already in your
pocket
as a final example consider self-driving
cars
while full adoption of self-driving cars
may still be
a few years away modern cars are able to
detect
obstacles in their environment and take
evasive action and some cars are even
able to completely drive themselves
so just consider this amazing feat of
engineering
that a car that you can buy these days
is able to actually detect what's going
on around it
and itself able to take driving
decisions which
used to be done by a human and so these
examples
very much form a motivation for
what i'm going to cover in those next
few modules so specifically
first i want to ask how is it possible
how is it possible
that we are now able to
solve such complicated machine
intelligence tasks
and second i want to ask given what we
know about
these machine intelligence tasks and how
they are solved can we learn anything
for applied econometrics and can we
learn anything from that that would
allow us
to perform some interesting analysis or
improve some analysis that we usually do
when we for example analyze a field
experiment
to understand better how modern machine
intelligence works
i want to start with one illustration
that i found a few years ago
in a new yorker so this is a story of
a cucumber farm in japan where
these three people which is a couple and
their son
run this farm together and so in order
to achieve a good price for cucumbers
it is very important to correctly
classify them
by their quality and usually that is the
job of the mother
which is on the right here and so now
the son
who's here on the left he wants to help
his mother
and ask how can i somehow help her with
a tedious task
of taking each cucumber and then
assessing its quality
and organizing it into different quality
categories and so what the sun does
is the sun builds a machine and that
machine
automatically takes pictures of each
cucumber
in order to decide what quality that
cucumber is
and so now what we see here is basically
a camera
attached to a computer together with
some contraption that makes sure
that you know one cucumber after the
other gets taken a picture of
and i now want to think about how would
we program that computer
in a way that the computer would allow
us
to see which quality cucumber it's
currently taking a picture of
and so in other words how could we
program this computer
in a way that would support the work of
the mother whose job
exactly that usually is taking a
cucumber deciding on its quality
so just take a moment and think about
that for yourself
you have a computer the computer takes a
picture you have this
big picture lots of pixels and now you
want to decide
is this a good cucumber or not
so note first that the structure of this
is very much the structure of what we
call a classification problem
we have some data which i call x
and and that data x here constitutes of
the many pixels of the pictures
and i want to look at this data x and
based on the data x
i want to decide what is the likely
quality of that cucumber so is that
a high quality gram a low cu quality
cucumber
and so i don't know about you but when i
first thought of that question
here is how i would have thought about
solving it i would have thought
about solving it by trying to understand
what are the features of a cucumber that
makes it of card quality
and then write some computer program
that tries to identify exactly those
properties
in my image for example maybe i would
have tried to write
a small program that tries to figure out
the specific pixels that belong to the
cucumber
or belong to the background and then
based on that for example
measure the color of the cucumber and
say this is a particularly good cucumber
if that color is very healthy it's a
very healthy green maybe i would have
also programmed
some small program that would try to
measure the curvature
of the cucumber and say you know
depending on the curvature and maybe
of the dimensions of the cucumber this
would be a cucumber that could sell for
a higher
or lower price and this is very much
how old style artificial intelligence
used to look like
so the idea here is that we try to
understand
how a human would take such decisions
and we then
code up a computer to do that
automatically so the computer would look
at different features of that picture
and based on those different features
the computer would then decide
is that a high quality cucumber or not
based on some rules that we code in
for example is it has it a certain
maximum of a certain curvature
does it have a healthy color and then if
it does have those things then
okay this is going to be a high quality
cucumber
so this approach to artificial
intelligence
was not very successful so instead
the modern way of doing artificial
intelligence
of doing machine intelligence
specifically of leveraging machine
learning is
to turn this question into a question
of effectively training on training data
and applying our knowledge on new data
in other words a question of statistics
so specifically that new style machine
learning
tries to induce the structure in a
mapping from pixels to cucumber quality
not by human intuition or introspection
but largely
from training data so how could that
work in this case
in this case we could take what is
called label data
so data where we already know which
quality
cucumber each of the pictures
corresponds to
and then fit a function that maps each
of those images
to one of the quality categories
and by fitting such a function we solve
this classification problem
by finding one that fits particularly
well
now what i just explained which is that
machine learning would solve this
intelligence task
by simply looking at training data
finding a function that maps the pixels
to the quality
and then applying that on new pictures
that it hasn't seen yet
well that very much just looks like
statistics in statistics we
also use some data often it has a form
of having some outcome variable y
some covariates x and we want to extract
some structure
that relates the x variables to my
variables so what is different here
well one first obvious difference
between the world of machine learning
that allows us to solve such problems as
the cucumber classification problem
is that the functions that make it work
look quite different
so think back to some say introductory
econometrics where
we are also fitting some relation
some function to the relationship
between outcome and
right-hand side variables so one
function that we may fit there is a
simple linear regression or maybe in the
case
where the outcome is binary so it's like
either high or low quality we would fit
something like
a logistic regression so if we fit a
logistic regression that may work well
for data
where there's only a few x variables but
in this case our x variables
are all the pixels of our
image and that is simply a very high
dimensional vector
for which the logit that we
have on the slide here wouldn't work
particularly well it wouldn't work
particularly well first
because the vector x is far too high
dimensional for it to work well
but second despite this vector x
being far too complex the function that
we fit it to
would not be complex enough to capture
the relationship
of pixels to quality well and that's
because
for understanding an image well we don't
just have to know whether each pixel is
say a one or a zero or has this color of
that color
we actually also have to understand how
neighboring pixels relate to each other
and in other words these like standard
functional forms
are very inadequate for a number of
reasons and
and the functions that we require here
much much more complex
so specifically what we may be using
here
rather than a simple logistic regression
is something called a neural network
where the outcome which is on the right
here
is not going to be a function simply of
the inputs not simply of the x variables
so the x variables are on the left here
but they are also a function of some
intermediate variables
in the middle here so think of this in
the following way
the output so my final prediction is
going to be
not a function of the pixels but it's
going to be something like a function
of functions of the pixels so it's going
to be something like
a logit of logits of my pixels
now in practice we don't just use logits
of logits
we actually use many many often more
than 10 such layers
and so as we move from simple neural
networks to deep learning we add more
and more layers and so in this example
for example
my prediction would be something like a
logit
of a logit of a logit of my input
variables
so when we therefore think about what
makes machine learning work and what
makes it different
from standard linear regression type
methods then a first
obvious difference is that it works with
much more flexible
richer data driven models than our
typical
linear regression approach and because
it does so it is actually able to work
with very high dimensional data such as
image data so we don't have to take a
very strong stance on just having
only a few variables we look at but we
can work with many more variables
let it be in images or in other data
now in order to make that work i will
argue in the next module
that we need two other crucial
ingredients
the first ingredient is that we actually
have to limit
the expressiveness of our functions to
avoid overfit
so that we make sure that what the
machine finds
when it searches through those very
complex functions isn't going to be
spurious and second we can actually use
the data to decide
how much of that expressiveness to allow
in other words how much to regularize
and which will be called
tuning a final nice feature
of these machine learning tools and it
makes them really influential is that
they are readily available so in
addition to those conceptual
breakthroughs
and i should say that some of those
insights had already been around in
statistics
for a very long time we now also have
the ability
to work with very complex data that is
rarely available
in an automated way because we have the
computational capacity
to do so and these tools
these software tools are also available
to all of us so just to give you an
example
in this cucumber example with the family
in japan the son of that family
was actually able to implement this
cucumber classifier
by leveraging an openly available tool
provided by google in this case
tensorflow
to solve this intelligence task and code
this up so all of us would be able
to actually implement that on our own
computers or
maybe in the cloud
so when i talk of features of machine
learning here
i should say that i'm going to focus on
one specific type of machine learning
and specifically i'm going to focus on
supervised machine learning that focuses
on prediction so i have some data
where i have labels so i have data we
have y's and x's
and i want to learn the relationship
between that y and that x
and the idea behind using machine
learning to solve the kind of tasks that
are motivated
at this talk with in the beginning was
to turn intelligence tasks into
supervised learning problems so cucumber
classification was one example
here it was about finding the good
cucumbers but you could also
think about doing something similar when
a bank or lender decides who to give
credit to
and works with past records of
somebody's financial behavior and wants
to decide
whether to give them credit which
basically boils down to trying to
predict
how likely that person is to default on
their loan
similarly in public policy we could
think of a tax authority
deciding which returns to audit usually
a human would go through
tax returns and check one which ones to
audit but here we could instead say
why don't we simply turn this into a
supervised learning problem
where the goal is to find those returns
that are problematic
and we use training data from the
existing audits
to find those other examples image
recognition and i want to pause for one
moment
and ask you how do you think of
self-driving cars in that context so
what would a self-driving car learn
from a supervised learning approach or
how could we train
a self-driving car using a supervised
learning approach
so just take a moment to think about it
i think
one first obvious way in which we could
leverage
supervised learning algorithms here are
in the kind of machine
intelligence image recognition way where
we
use the images that a sensor of a
self-driving car generates
and then use that in order to for
example identify obstacles identify
trees and then
we can write a rule that says you know
if there's a tree we should probably not
drive against it
but my point here just to drive this
point home is that
if we wanted to program a self-driving
car we could
do it in an even simpler way we could do
it in a way that is purely a task of
supervised learning or prediction
it doesn't have to be the best one and
certainly not the the way that
self that state-of-the-art self-driving
cars end up working
but just to kind of highlight the power
of this paradigm
what you could have done is you could
have simply taken all the
sensor inputs as your x variable and as
you buy variable you could have taken
the steering actions of a human you
could have simply predicted what does a
human do when a human is in that or that
situation based on all these sensor
inputs and
using that you could implement the first
self-driving car
that takes all these sensors as input it
knows which situation is into that but
you don't hold up anything about
the logic of driving you simply rely on
learning what a human would do in a
similar situation
again i'm not saying that this is how a
state-of-the-art
self-driving cars are actually in the
end working because for them we want to
have a lot of more guardrails we want to
actually know a little bit more what's
going on
but just embracing this idea of
supervised learning this is how we could
do it
so in addition to being widely available
supervised learning has also been
incredibly successful
and i just want to highlight that with
one small example
and that example is going to be image
recognition
so there is a standardized data set and
a standardized competition
in order to evaluate the quality and
of machine learning predictors in image
recognition
and that is called imagenet so the
database of many images
and using those images the competition
is basically about i give you
a large training data set with many of
the images where the images are already
labeled so for each image
i tell you what it is and then i give
you a new set of images
where i don't tell you what they show
and i ask your
machine learning algorithm to tell me
what the machine learning algorithm can
identify in those pictures and
because you haven't seen yet what the
grand truth theory is i can then compare
that to what that image really shows
so here for example are a number of
images
as well as their true label meaning what
they really show and
the best guesses by one of
the machine learning algorithms
that was tested on this data set
so for example the second on the
left on the top would be a container
ship and in that case
despite not knowing that this is a
container ship the machine learning
algorithm correctly identified as to be
most likely a container ship
so it is a container ship and the
machine learning algorithm says that's
most likely so in this case
machine learning algorithm was right let
me give you one example where the
machine learning algorithm
got it slightly wrong so this picture on
the bottom here
second from the right is actually
characterized as cherry
and the machine learning algorithm says
this was
a dark which actually makes a lot of
sense because there's also dark visible
in the picture so in this case
what the machine algorithm learning
algorithm says actually makes a lot of
sense despite it being
not a correct classification here
another one here on the right is
a madagascar cut honestly i wouldn't
have known it myself
and the machine learning algorithm says
this is likely going to be a squirrel or
a monkey
a squirrel monkey sorry which i think is
a totally reasonable guess but in this
case would be
considered a mistake so
before i go to show you the results of
how well machine learning does i just
want you guys to think
first what do you think how many
mistakes would a machine learning
algorithm
make on these pictures and second as i
just said even i got it wrong
like how good would a human be and so
the number
i'm about to look at will be the percent
that we get wrong
so we ask the algorithm or we ask a
human to classify each of those pictures
and we compare it against the labels we
have
on new data where the machine learning
algorithm hasn't seen the ground truth
and then we count in how many percent of
cases
does the machine learning algorithm get
it wrong
so without further ado let me get to the
results
so this is how the performance of the
top performing machine learning
algorithm has developed
over the last 10 or so years
so first to start with machines got it
wrong around one third of the time
which to be honest is already pretty
impressive had i not known anything
about machine learning i would have been
impressed
by a machine learning algorithm that
gets it right two thirds of the time
when assigning such detailed labels
but the really shocking thing is that
this improved massively
over the last 10 years alone and i don't
have up-to-date data here
so by 2017 it had already hit around two
percent so i assume this is now
um around two percent mistakes
what is even more remarkable about that
that a human gets it wrong
around five percent of the time
so in other words machines are now
systematically outperforming humans in
something
that we would have thought as one of the
things that humans are particularly good
at
which is in this case image recognition
now i presented here advances in
supervised learning in other words
advances in prediction
for example imagine image recognition
the results i just shared show the
incredible success of machine learning
at solving supervised learning or
prediction tasks
but the success of machine learning goes
far beyond those supervised learning
tasks and i think there are many
other areas we will hopefully be able to
learn from
so specifically there is a whole area of
so-called unsupervised learning
which tries to find structure in data
where there are no labels
but instead for example tries to find
clusters
of points that look similar to each
other
another example in that space is topic
modeling that we can for example apply
powerfully to understand structure in
texts
so topic models aim to
group documents for example by their
topics
in order to automatically extract
structure from massive corpora of text
that would then allow us
to understand for example how text has
changed systematically over time how
certain topics have changed over time
and or what the prevalent themes in a
large body of text is
i want to end this small overview over
the successes of machine learning
on one other example that has a slightly
different structure
but i think shows nicely how far we've
come from classical artificial
intelligence
and all the way to where we are these
days with modern machine learning
and that is humans playing against
computers or more specifically
computers more and more winning against
humans at very complex games
like chess and go
so when computers first beat humans
convincingly a chess
the idea behind the programs used there
was very much still one in the classical
paradigm of artificial intelligence
where we use expert knowledge where we
use human
understanding of the logic of the game
and experience
in order to code up explicit rules how
the computer should play chess
but modern computers and specifically
those that first one convincingly
against humans at go specifically
alphago
they actually work much more like modern
supervised learning in that they are
trained on existing plays
by computers but also by humans
in order to learn how good humans play
in order to learn
and mimic them in order to learn how to
play against them
but now the even more modern
programs that win convincingly both
against humans and against for example
alphago
for example alpha zero they work on an
even
more advanced paradigm where they don't
even require anymore
to learn against humans they are able to
completely only play against themselves
and by doing so and finding
good plays that are dominant both
against human play and against
computer play
so with these motivating facts
about the tremendous success of machine
learning i now want to go back
to the goal of this webinar so
specifically
we are not going to teach you
state-of-the-art machine learning here
or how to fit your neural
net this webinar is much more about
trying to connect this world of machine
learning
to the world of applied econometrics
and behavioral science where we want to
use machine learning as a tool
specifically we think there are plenty
of resources out there to learn machine
learning
as well as the statistics behind it not
just the kind of deep learning that i
just hinted at
but also the more statistical learning
that is
sometimes more applicable to the kind of
data sets that we have in behavioral and
social sciences
and so rather than showing you
how to use those machine learning tools
technically we want to
show you how to use them conceptually
and how you can apply them concretely in
program evaluation
and so specifically my goal for the next
two of those modules will be to present
you with a framework
for using and critically evaluating
machine learning in applied econometrics
on which we will then build in order to
bring it together with typical tasks
in causal inference and program
evaluation
and so specifically we want to end on
giving you some concrete tools
in which with which machine learning can
actually enhance
applied work so throughout i should
clarify
i will focus on supervised learning on
social science type data
so i will neither deal a lot with
unsupervised learning
or for example topic modeling nor will i
dive deep
into solving machine learning problems
when we indeed have like very large
pixel maps
that we want to learn from or we want to
solve image classification problems i
will be much more concerned
with difficult social science type data
sets where for example we may want to
predict house prices from the
characteristics of houses
only may want to learn who we should
target
when we think of eradicating poverty
i will also only touch on some of the
technical challenges
implementation a lot of work has gone
into making
all these things computationally
feasible and making code available that
efficiently run so that you can run
many of those methods on your computer i
will take most of this as given
and i will focus on using those tools
rather than
rather than kind of coding up these
tools ourselves
but i will try to give you enough
understanding of how they work so that
you conceptually know
what to look for and where you should be
careful
and where you can hope that those tools
can help you improve your work
finally i should flag that this is very
much work in progress on an evolving
agenda
so many of the things that we're going
to talk about are very close to current
research
and they may as well change over the
next few years so with that
this is the structure of my part on
machine learning basics
today in this module i went over an
introduction
where i argued that a lot of what is
driving modern machine intelligence
has the structure of a prediction
exercise where it takes some training
data
that training data has some outcome y
some right hand side variable x which
looks very much like statistics
and i now learn a function from that in
order to apply it to new instances
tomorrow in our next module we want to
understand
what the secret source of machine
learning is we want to understand
what makes this kind of prediction be so
successful
when it seems a very very hard task if
we were to use our standard mach
our standard linear regression tools
which hardly would fit
to something like a complex pixel map
and in my third and last module
of this first big chapter of our webinar
i
want to then end on characterizing the
differences between
the techniques that come from machine
learning and those that we typically use
in econometrics
by pointing out that the two of them
fulfill different goals
and i will want to use that in order
to provide a bit of a framework of where
we can use machine learning most
profitably
and where we have to be particularly
careful in using it
see you then